Hey folks, I’ve got a bunch of projects in the
works cooking up for later, and I’ve been loving
Edge of Eternities so far, so I figured this was
a lovely time for a precon review. I put it up to
a vote, and my Patrons narrowly chose the World
Shaper precon, so that’s what we’re going to look
at in this video. Here’s the format—I’m going to
tell you what I think this deck is trying to do,
I’m going to talk about the areas it succeeds
in, and then we can talk about its weaknesses,
and a set of card swaps that could
help out with those. To start with,
let’s talk about the commander. Hearthhull, the
Worldseed is a 4 mana Spacecraft in Jund colors,
with Spacecraft being a new artifact subtype
that’s being introduced in Edge of Eternity.
They’re artifacts that can basically be leveled
up by tapping creatures to gain more abilities,
similar to crewing a vehicle, and a lot of them
eventually become creatures as well. This set
also brings a rules change to the commander format
where any legendary vehicle or spacecraft with a
power/toughness box can be in the command zone,
and over on the podcast I cohost we just did
a tier list of all vehicle commanders, which
will be linked down in the description. Okay,
so that’s spacecraft, but what does Hearthhull in
particular do? Nothing at first, but once it’s had
two power put into it it gains the ability to tap,
pay 1, and sacrifice a land to draw two cards and
gain an additional land play this turn. At eight
charge counters, it becomes a 6/7 with flying,
vigilance, haste, and “Whenever you sacrifice
a land, each opponent loses two life.”
Initial impressions—this seems like a solid value
engine with some explosive endgame utility. If
we squint a bit, we can kind of think of its
first ability as having a floor of tapping to
draw a card, since we’ll probably draw and play
another land from those two cards pretty often,
repaying the 1 mana if it entered untapped.
This is a fine starting point, but obviously
there are a whole lot of things that amplify
the power of this. The biggest one is things
that can utilize lands in our graveyard—if we’re
able to get them back out into play in some form,
this card represents a fair amount of ramp
potential in addition to the value it provides.
Another amplifier would be landfall effects
that benefit from additional lands entering,
and third would be payoffs for permanents being
sacrificed, and if we can get some number of
these online the 2+ ability on Hearthhull will
pack a ton of utility. The 8+ modality is a bit
less appealing to me to get to early on, since
it makes our commander more removable without
putting on much pressure in most cases, but
it’s a nice tool to have in our toolbox as
something that can be turned on right before a
big land-sacrifice play. Overall, a nice package.
So, how does this deck work with this
commander? Well there are six cards that
can recur multiple lands from the graveyard,
three instantaneous and three more gradual,
along with a number of other cards that
can sacrifice lands to perform effects.
This, to me, represents a core ramp engine of the
deck—sacrificing lands to perform various effects
before spitting those sacrificed lands back out
into play, building a lot of mana and value in
the process. Mana and value don’t win games,
though, so what are our payoffs for futzing
with lands? Three main things—four landfall
cards, nine payoffs for sacrificing permanents,
and four cards that check the number of lands
in graveyards, with most of these payoff cards
amplifying a player’s board or pushing damage
in some way. To support this gameplan, there’s a
pretty wide and diverse removal suite, as well as
a deliciously high land count of 42. So to recap,
this deck is trying to build mana and value
through the process of sacrificing and replaying
lands before turning things up to 11 with a suite
of permanents that perform powerful effects when
parts of this cycle happen. The endgame plan is
likely going to be a mixture of large creatures,
moderate-sized creature tokens, and
potentially an explosive burst of
life loss from the commander if things line just
right. So, what do I think about this gameplan?
Let’s talk about what I like about this deck, and
since this is a lands deck, I’m gonna mix things
up and talk about the deck’s manabase first.
Overall, there’s quite a lot to be excited about
here. First of all, 42 lands is a fair amount, but
with a commander that both sacrifices lands and
gives extra land plays, this number is perfectly
reasonable. In terms of raw manabase quality,
things are pretty great here—great symbol counts
in black and green and a fine enough symbol count
in red given that it’s a secondary color. Like
the last precon I reviewed, we have a moderately
large count of taplands here, but given the high
total land count, I don’t see this really being
an issue. More to the point of what’s cool about
this manabase, there’s an impressive density of
budget fetches here—a whole 10! I’ll admit that
I was at first a little skeptical of the the two
tapped fetches and especially the three Capenna
fetches here, but these start to make a lot more
sense when you remember that the four most
powerful land recursion spells in the deck
return the lands to play tapped, which isn’t a
downside for any of these five. And the upside
of these is immense—these tie into all three
of our main payoff types, those being lands in
graveyard payoffs, permanent sacrificing payoffs,
and landfall effects. The amount of utility these
subtly add to the deck is really cool. Finally
let’s talk about the typed duals—we have all three
of both tango lands and bicycle lands, which can
be fetched with any card grabbing a basic-typed
land. And yes, that includes the Golgari ones as
well—the commander team at Wizards is continuing
in their quest to flesh out dual land cycles in
precons, and I’m super here for it. These are
lovely for any players who want dual types
and don’t want to shell out for one of the
more expensive options—even just having a little
extra upside over a basic tapland is really nice.
Okay, so how does this deck build off of this
strong foundation of lands? Let’s talk about
the core engine here—this deck is looking to
sacrifice lands, oftentimes recur those lands,
and generally get payoffs from the act of playing
and sacrificing lands. In practice, this mostly
works out. If there’s one thing this deck can
do, it’s get lands into the graveyard—between
the commander, 10 fetches, and 13 cards in the 99
that sacrifice lands, this deck is very consistent
at finding ways to fill its graveyard with lands,
should it want to do such a thing. For recurring
lands, there’s a somewhat lower quantity,
though this is to be expected for a payoff card,
and the deck for the most part seems high-velocity
enough to find these—it tends to churn through a
lot of cards. When they are found, the impact
can be big—even relatively early in the game,
finding one of the deck’s three mass land
recursion cards can routinely grab 4 or more
lands. I ran a number of playtests with this
deck out to the end of turn 5, and there were
a surprising number of them where I finished with
10 or even 12 lands in play, which can set up the
deck for some serious midgame shenanigans if
it can keep finding its way into nonland plays.
How about payoffs outside of land recursion?
As I mentioned earlier, two major payoff types
are landfall and permanent sacrifice, and
these both play pretty cool roles here,
particularly the former. Landfall is a
great tool here because it doesn’t even
require much extra setup—with the deck’s 10
fetchlands and extra land play commander,
you’re already looking at anywhere from 2-4
lands entering per turn, and that’s before
taking into account ramp or land recursion. There
are three powerful finishers utilizing this fact,
as well as Tireless Tracker as a lovely value
engine. Permanent-sacrifice payoffs exist in a
somewhat similar realm—the commander sacrifices a
land every turn, and tack a single fetchland per
turn on top of that and you’re looking at two
easy triggers per turn, before considering the
13 nonland cards that can help with this task.
A lot of these payoffs are pretty sweet—you’ve
got classic Jund powerhouses like Korvold and
Mayhem Devil, as well as some neat new ones
printed for this precon. I have opinions about
the exact quantity of these here that I’ll get
to a little later, but the bottom line here
is that I really like this structuring for
the deck. This deck will be at its best when
it’s able to perform land recursion, but most
of these landfall and sacrifice payoff cards have
a high enough floor that they’ll feel perfectly
fine even if the deck is currently operating at a
somewhat lower caliber. This, to me, is ideal for
a precon—you want to give newer players a chance
to pop off and be the big bad sometimes, but you
also want their deck to chug along and make them
feel like they’re getting to play even if they’re
not having some sort of big gamer turn, and most
of this deck’s payoffs accomplish that goal.
Moving on to this deck’s removal suite, things
continue to look pretty solid—five pieces of
instant speed, single-target removal, five pieces
of multi-removal, and then another seven cards
that perform some sort of hybrid role, being a
removal engine or performing another task as well.
I’ll highlight some favorites here, but the key
takeaway here is that this removal suite is just
pretty great, and there’s only one card here
I find even remotely worth cutting. This deck
is obviously a big Mayhem Devil W, and I also
love Windgrace’s Judgement and Pest Infestation
as powerful multi-removal options in decks that
can afford to pay up a bit of mana. There’s two
pieces of graveyard exile here, but it might
feel like a lot more in practice since this
deck is high-velocity and has the capability to
loop Bojuka Bog to its heart’s content. We also
have to talk about Planetary Annihilation—this
is a wild new design, dealing 6 damage to each
creature and forcing each player to sacrifice down
to 6 lands. To discuss the card’s merits here,
it works really satisfyingly with both the
commander and this deck’s sources of mass
land recursion, and outside of that I was
nothing short of electrified to see this
sort of effect printed in a precon in the first
place. I wear the conflicting hats of big mana
player and advocate for incomplete mana wipes
such as this, and while I don’t want to derail
this video with a whole by jumping away to talk
about that for five minutes, I did discuss my
thoughts on this card and some others from
Edge of Eternity in a segment available to
Patrons and YouTube members, and there will
be a preview of that at the end of the video.
Okay, so that’s what I like about this deck—a
fair amount. But what do I dislike about this
precon? Only really two things—it lacks early game
utility plays, and it has too much land sacrifice
and sacrifice payoff, especially considering that
the commander is both of these things already.
So, the way we’re gonna go about improving this
is that we’re going to cut some of the trickier
payoffs and replace them with other payoff
cards that are more flexible, and we’re also
going to add a handful of cards for purposes of
smoothing the deck’s early game and helping with
setup. Unlike basically all of my previous precon
reviews, I’m not really going to be introducing
any new elements to the deck—the ideas are already
here, we just need to commit a bit harder to the
better choices in the deck. Let’s start with
cuts. First, Loamcrafter Faun—unless you just
want an outlet to discard lands, which I don’t
think this deck wants, the two requirements to
make the ETB good won’t be lining up often enough.
Scouring Swarm is honestly just a pretty mediocre
card—obviously flying is nice and there’s a
bit of explosive potential, but each of the
conditions are too difficult to meet to justify
their respective payoffs, and it doesn’t even
have 2 power to get Hearthhull juiced up in one
go. World Breaker costs way too much mana for
the utility it provides this deck, so it’s also
gotta go. Sprouting Goblin at least accomplishes
a couple tasks the deck vaguely wants, but the
overall package here is still a bit meh. Likewise,
I sort of see the vision with Groundskeeper
and I’d be okay with it if it was a 2/1, but as
things stand the use cases for it just aren’t wide
enough. Uurg, Spawn of Turg sadly just doesn’t do
enough for my liking, being neither a great early
game play nor a particularly ideal later play.
Finally, this deck is just a bit overloaded on
higher cost and trickier to use payoffs, and the
two I’m choosing to cut here are Mazirek, Kraul
Death Priest and Centaur Vinecrasher. If you love
those cards, I dunno, pretend I named two other
payoff cards you like a bit less. The specifics
aren’t that important for these last two cuts,
we’re just trying to rebalance the ratios a bit.
Now onto the additions—first of all and by orders
of magnitude most importantly, Spelunking. Land
untapping effects are disgustingly powerful in
this deck, and the options out there other than
Spelunking are quite pricey. Next up, I did cut
some land-sacrificing payoffs, and the logical
replacement to me is landfall. Lotus Cobra and
Tireless Provisioner are both great mana engines,
and Valakut Exploration is a great value
engine that doubles as a damage wincon in
a big land-fiddling turn, potentially working in
tandem with the commander to one-shot opponents
from shockingly high life totals. Next up, I wanna
get some higher-utility two drops in here. This
deck has a lot of late game potential, but is
a little clunky right now and hungry for early
smoothers. Deeproot Wayfinder is a pretty sweet
little guy that can filter and ramp a bit early,
and maybe even a bit later too if we can keep a
path clear for him. House Cartographer is a neat
card to help us keep up a steady flow of lands to
hand, and our commander’s Station ability gives
an easy way to trigger survival once attacks
are off the table. Another card I added was
Undergrowth Recon, as this deck seems like it
could use a bit more land recursion. Honestly,
I think you could even look into adding another
1-2 beyond this, but the other ones out there
tend to start around the three dollar mark, and
if you’re looking for the best bang for your buck
you’re gonna be best off grabbing Spelunking and
some landfall cards as your first upgrades over
a dollar. The final nonland card I added is Hugs,
Grisly Guardian. This deck could use both another
little boost of draw and another additional land
play enabler, so I suppose you could add Curse
of the Locked Hothouse as an alternative,
but I’ve definitely already given that card
plenty of attention on this channel, and Hugs
brings that lovely Badger energy to the table.
Those are the 8 nonland swaps, but I’m also
choosing to swap two lands out. For one,
the Wastes, which I guess was here as a
basic-typed way to pay for World Breaker’s
ability? Maybe? Let’s go with that. The other land
cut is Dakmor Salvage—dredge is cute, but I don’t
think this is actually likely to ever do a lot
outside of being a black tapland. In their place,
I bring in Twisted Landscape, a pretty high
quality tri-fetch, as well as Kessig Wolf Run,
which can be a mana sink and a way to give trample
to one of the deck’s large-but-non-trampling
creatures. With that, my 10 swaps are done here.
Sometimes I do more than that, but in this case
this deck is just looking pretty good, it doesn’t
need much extra help. The base list is a little
payoff-heavy, which I imagine most players will
figure out at some point, and giving them the
option of what to cut and which directions to
push harder in is a reasonable enough task.
The new cards for this deck are interesting—on the
one hand my two least-favorite cards in this list
were new additions specifically for this deck,
which is a little odd, but some of the other newly
printed cards are fantastic and do great things
for this deck. Evendo Brushrazer is a fantastic
value engine, Horizon Explorer is a much welcome
additional Amulet of Vigor effect with some neat
upside, and Planetary Annihilation is a wild
board wipe with a ton of different use cases.
I love the creative design space this
precon is exploring, and the strange
and land-fiddling nature of the deck fits the
flavor of Edge of Eternity perfectly to me.
Thanks for watching, and thanks to Archidekt
for supporting the channel. Archidekt’s category
system and smooth UI really helps me out in
analyzing decks and making reviews like this one,
and a link to the final upgraded list is in the
description. I also want to thank my Patrons,
some of whom are on screen now, and if you feel
like joining them in supporting the channel,
you’ll get access to a bonus video where
I discuss my thoughts on some EoE cards
for about half an hour. A preview for
that video will start riiiiiight now!